مرحبا في كل موسم درامي رمضاني ومن بين
عشرات الاعمال اللي يشاهدها دائما في وجه
جديد يلفت النظر سينتهي رمضان وتبدا بعده
رحله هذا الوجه الجديد مع النجوميه على
سبيل المثال خلال السنوات الماضيه اكتشفنا
من خلال دراما رمضان عدم الشرقاوي رنه
رئيس مايان السيد ورحمه احمد في كذا وجه
جديد بس انا اكتر حد عجبني وانا مش عارف
اسمها البنت الصغيره اللي عملت دور اختي
ياسمين عبد العزيز في ضرب نار انا حاولت
اوصل
لاسمها ما لقيتوش على موقع السينما ولا
على جوجل
حلو قوي يعني انا حسيت انها مش عيله صغيره
بتمثل لا دي ممثله فدي اكتر حد لفت
انتباهك انا لسه ما عنديش الاسم الليبي
يعني
بس بره بشوف ان الريسكس دي بتتاخد عادي
احنا ما عندناش الثقافه دي قوي ولكن
ابتدينا شويه نعملها بمسلسل بالطو في احمد
طبعا بيمثل من زمان ولكن هو لسه شاب فانه
عامل مسلسل بطوله السنه اللي فاتت في
رمضان والسنه دي عامل بطوله فشاف ان
الثقافه دي ابتدت تتعمل عندنا شويه فاتمنى
اكون عندي
هذا العام هناك العديد من الاوجه الجديده
للفتاه الانظار انظار الصحافه والجمهور
ايضا كلا منهم لفت النظر في مكان ماو على
خط معين هناك من لفه النظر في التراجيديا
وهناك من لفت النظر في الكوميديا دائما
رمضان بيبقى فرصه لظهور الوجوه الجديده
مساحات كبيره بياخدها كتير من الفنانين
الشباب صعب طبعا نحكم في الايام الاولى
لكن انا جذب انتباهي الفنان الشاب احمد
عبد الوهاب بدور ضابط الشرطه في مسلسل
يسرا الف حمد لله على السلامه كمان الممثل
كريم محجوب اللي هو قائم مدور السائق طارق
في مسلسل
علاقه مشروعه مسلسل الكتيبه 101 في العديد
من الفنانين الشباب اليمين بدور الجنود
والعساكر في الجيش المصري معظمهم مميزين
الجمهور احب بعض الاسماء الجديده جدا
وتنبا لها بمستقبل فني ناجح من كانت تلك
[موسيقى]
الاسماء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات